foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
thank you welcome to the meeting of
external overview and scrutiny committee
at Storage District Council on Tuesday
the 13th of June 2023 and it's the first
external meeting of this Council
um I need to remind you that there's no
fire alarms expected
is there anything else I need to
fire accents
have we got any apologies for absence
yesterday we've had apologies from
councilor back and councilor bushby is
substituting we've had apologies from
councilor craigie we've had apologies
from councilor Shepard and councilor
Hodson is substituting and we've had
apologies from Kenton Baker the
independent person okay thank you and
can I agree the minutes of the previous
meetings please
page three
four
five
six
seven
eight
do I go straight on to the next
chair of voting on the um minutes for
the first of February and I think the
15th of March wasn't Quarry so they're
just for negative okay
um I was present at the Wednesday the
1st of February so I'll propose that and
councilor Harding a second
um votes in favor
can you vote in favor if you want that
or anything because it's only if you're
at the meeting
so
councilor Hawkins were you there
four of us before and any against
and abstentions if you weren't there
okay
so that's doing it
and then any public participation today
none chair there would be
and the action list page 14.
137 Southwest water provide the copy of
presentation we've got that as going on
going
um is there any updates I noticed on the
full Council agenda there's
no information about water quality so
I'm guessing that will sort of pass if
that's agreed that'll pass to them
yes
so do we just leave it there
yeah
okay
thank you and
154 report from Dentistry commissioning
team any update
no update on that one chair
um I think at the last meeting it was
explained that um the Commissioners who
we requested to attend this meeting
um explained that they already report to
Devon County Council so we were in
contact I think
Germany as chair was contacting
um counselor the yeah councilor Helia is
the county councilor I'm not sure where
that
um where that is now though so I can
chase that you know right through look
into that again and double check the
counter Council
um 182 raise concerns regarding the end
of support for energy costs letters
Center
Adrian Avery met councilors and
councilor Hudson about the westerto
Green Park condition and that's
completely happy with that
stuff that
they liked knocked out before cancer
what was the outcome which
is
bacteria
so
um
good thank you and 192.
right to MP to raise concerns regarding
lack of clarity And Delay to that our
future Hospital program and the proposed
building program at North Devon District
Hospital site that letter is attached to
this agenda but it was only sent
a few days ago so we're still waiting
for response to that
um
yeah can I just say that I saw my
husband's tablet because mine doesn't
work
um and I just think you need to be much
more specific about what information we
want from the trust I was on the trust
board for eight years and I know that
both them and Cox if they don't know
what you want specifically they'll give
you a rather Anodyne answer in all cases
so I just think we need to have a
schedule and I've asked because I
haven't got this the minutes for this
because this doesn't work I think we
need to know the project they've got in
Hand by the Departments they're
refurbishing and those they're not
because they can't possibly do the whole
hospital it would be a new hospital
and also the budgets for each different
department in terms of where the money's
going to come from because Cyril does
ask that a question in her letter and I
think we need to know what the money is
because that's not clear so um I just
think that we need to be much more
specific about this it's a very very
important issue in our community and
obviously who knows what kind of
disruption they'll be on top of the
benefits
so I think we must you know get a handle
on this really and I'm sure the um MP if
he can not say anything
he probably will
okay I just like to have some more
information about that yeah yeah
um and I did speak to Stacy about it and
we were going to say um a lot there's a
lot of new councilors here obviously
that weren't at that meeting and we can
get the slides sent around to everybody
and we could write a letter to request
more detail
so Joe what I do after the meeting
um but they presented to us on the 15th
of March so I will email the minutes
around for for all members and then
email the presentation as well and then
after that point
um if there's further questions that
members wanna
um raise then
um with your agreement chair then we can
write asking further questions to the
trust yeah
because I did that I thought that my
letter was quite direct actually because
I did ask specific questions that I
wanted answering rather than being too
generic yep
oh can you turn on your mic is it sorry
I realize you've written to uh Sir
Jeffrey Cox but the hospital is actually
in I believe in the constituency of
slade Saxby although she's not our MP is
it worth also sending the same questions
to her
I think that's a valid point
[Music]
should we write that one
councilor Hardy
yeah I understand that um
portal hospitals at Midstate on the uh
funding now and it's a
it's not uh going to be put through as
soon as we thought
um they've they're prioritizing Rural
and others and it looks like a Borough
North haven't been left behind again I'm
not sure I mean I saw that on the news
the other day and I was a bit upset
it'll be interesting to hear hear back
from the letter from Jeffrey Cox and
slain Saxby and what they have to say
and we've asked them that letter for it
to be put to the Prime Minister as well
so I'm trying to take care of them oh
nagging Saturday I'm seeing him yes
please yeah
I'd like to nag him
um
so that's the action list
sorry chair can I just return to this
issue about Dentistry
um I know we've uh emailed councilor
Helia
as a member of the County Council
but
if that was the 7th of December and
we've had no response
to our inquiries do we need to escalate
this to John Hart
and actually ask what committee is
responsible for this and what the latest
position is about bidding for contracts
for
dentistry in Northern Devon where it's
acute as it is all across Devon and I
think we need to have an answer to this
because it's one of the biggest issues
about not being able to get
to see a dentist
for adults and more importantly for
young people for children because if
they don't go to the dentist for three
or four years and it becomes an
emergency then it becomes major
treatment which can be really traumatic
for a child
so I think we need to escalate this
issue and take it out further do we know
who the cabinet member is that would be
send it to the leader and the cabinet
member for that department because
obviously they've had a report to them
so then they can update us to the
situation thank you thank you
next Declarations of Interest members of
Interest should refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interests when the item is considered
number six
urgent matters brought forward of the
permission of the chair I did have the
letter that we've already discussed as
it was on the action list as well
and also I've been contacted by a few
people and including councilor craigie
who wanted me to mention about concern
over the potential closure of the link
center in Biddeford and in Northern
Devon
so I said I'd raise it under urgent
matters and didn't know if that would
link together with the forward plan if
we could send another letter to the
County Council so I would propose the
chief executive the leader and the
cabinet member I think is councilor
James McInnis from happily and o'campton
area
raising our concern and asking someone
to come and speak to us in detail about
what they are doing to improve mental
health outcomes for the people of Torrid
and in relation to the potential closure
of the link center that would be a
proposal for me as the chair is there a
second
councilor Smith
and there's a favor
unanimous
excuse me can I just can I just say this
this issue seems to crop out time and
again it gets dealt with and then
six months or a year down the line we
hear the threatened with closure again
this is an ongoing situation we've
really got to address it
thank you
um I'm here this morning to substitute
for somebody 12 hours ago I got an
invitation to join the adult and social
care scrutiny committee at Dublin County
Council which is also being held this
morning
now obviously I've made a commitment to
be here and to be up to speed reading
the documentation when I didn't get it
until last night so I sent my apologies
but one of the issues on the agenda
was the link centers and the results of
the consultation
so if my nomination because I've only
just been nominated to this committee if
it's accepted and it goes through I will
ask if I can circulate the minutes of
that meeting
um relating to the link center yes
please thank you thank you
I'm just going to add to councilor
hodgson's because we did respond in that
consultation as well because Council
Hodgson forwarded that to us
um explaining
um
how bad it would be from a toridge
perspective if we lost the links Center
so I would assume that others have
responded in a similar vein but I too
would have been interested in the
outcome of the meeting I think
unfortunately we were asked to nominate
on Thursday Friday last week and then
receive notification last night that the
meeting was this morning so it's um it's
unfortunate but hopefully if Council
hodgson's on that the meeting then we
always get the update as to what they
intend on doing but we did respond
criticizing
um that and the obvious knock-on effects
that it would have on toridge as a whole
agreement of and the items part one and
two there's no part two
and then we've got number eight an
introduction to the scrutiny roll
it's even update from Stacy
morning then
I'm sorry I haven't got my microphone on
um external bodies that that storage
fund and work with of
the policing Justice that and crime and
disorder again gives us a statutory
responsibility to work alongside
the police to help reduce crime and
disorder but we also have other
statutory functions so we we will deal
with um statutory nuisance matters so
loud noise smells that side of it so
there's there's lots of statutory
responsibilities that torridge as a
Authority will deal with out we deal
with licenses
um that side of it so that's effectively
what the crime of disorder Act is we're
legally obliged and we work alongside
the police we'll have joint meetings
with the police with a view to trying to
reduce
anti-social behavior
and you know with us working with them
we have limited powers but often the low
level nuisance can often increase to
obviously more serious nuisance matters
so
the next slide please Tom
as I've just said
um external
um we monitor the performance of of the
partners and external bodies
um now from from an external point of
view and bodies that we don't find I
mean we've just been speaking
um briefly about them that the NHS and
the Dentistry we can always ask
um those bodies to come to external but
we can't force them to to attend and
answer our questions but with the ones
that we fund obviously we often have
contracts performance contracts and one
of their requirements is that they
specifically report to to external
um on a yearly basis or sometimes a six
monthly basis
um so those sorts of bodies would be
um we've got a list later on but one's
like active torrage
um well you'll be monitoring the
performance what they do any questions
and they will report to you and directly
answer your your your questions
so the role of scrutiny
is to act as a critical friend
um to act as the critical friends
regarding all matters that might come
through Council
and to voice concerns and issues that
the local community have have raised to
you now
scrutiny itself doesn't have any
decision-making Powers but what you do
have the power to do is make
recommendations to full Council if
there's something that you disagree with
or if there's
um a matter that you think isn't quite
right then you have the power to refer
that back to full Council to make an
alternative recommendation
so one of your critical
um this is our what it states in our
Constitution and this is really what the
committee will be guided by
um but your critical one is the right to
call then so
you can call in a decision that has been
made but not yet implemented and when I
say not yet implemented when our
committees make a decision so Community
Resources for example
um
that decision isn't actually implemented
we have a five-day calling off period
and effectively that five-day calling
off period is to enable it to be called
in and scrutinized once it's been made
um so after this on the sixth day that
decision will be implemented so that's
it you you can't call it in then so
you've got five days so if for example
CNR make a decision
today
um
that will be the decision notice will be
issued and we send that around to all
councilors now if there's something that
you have a concern with in relation to
that decision or not even a concern
necessarily
um a question to ask then you must call
that in within five days and then it
will be on the agenda for the next
external scrutiny committee
may I just ask you if that's five
calendar days or five working days
I think we do it as five working days
but I will check that yeah yeah no no no
that if it's making me think
I think we had a question about this
before because Saturday became a working
day as well so
um we need some clarity on this because
most of us around the table will see
Monday to Friday but I think Saturday is
has the possibility or potential to be
counted so a response on that front
would be useful no and that's a point
point well made by Tom and I are
scratching our heads so
yeah um we'll clarify that after the
meeting it should be working days
um also it's four members of council
isn't it is it four members oh so is it
coming up
and yeah call officers and to account
onto the petition scheme so at the back
of the Constitution
um we have a petition scheme where any
residents umtorage can submit a petition
in relation to a matter affecting
torrage it's it's got to affect storage
and it's got to be something that
torridge District have uh control over
um so that's one of the things that can
come to scrutiny effectively your power
was in relation to questions to ask and
call in are quite unlimited or unlimited
really but what we would always say is
make sure it's something that is
relevant to to the storage inhabitants
and we had one before didn't we show
everyone
um Dartmoor and we were kind of
scratching our heads but of course in
relation to that a lot of our residents
do do use start more in the wild words
so it's something that we've got to be
able to have a sale control over really
um and the other thing as you'll see
question members of the council's
Committees the chairperson so
effectively
officers
can ask for any member or officer to to
attend a committee if if needed
I've just sort of run through that that
that briefly but effectively anything
that affects storage or its inhabitants
yeah we've been through that
um so this is the committee makeup
we have a
only one on elective representative at
the moment are just speaking to
um Tom about that earlier so we will
um go out and add
um advertise well we've historically
really struggled to recruit independent
people
um so if you know of anyone who is
interested
um councilor back was one of our
independent persons but now he's
obviously been elected as a district
councilor he he can't be we've got one
currently covering this committee Canton
Baker he's also a member of our
standards an independent person on our
standards committee also
um but he wasn't able to attend today
but that that's a really important
function someone completely independent
on torrage and being able to ask
um questions
and we allowed the non-elected
representatives to vote at committee
meetings also because otherwise it seems
a bit pointless having an independent
member who can't person who can't
scrutinize our decisions as well
Stacy can you
um for for new members the role of an
independent person
is an unpaid or um
there is no no remuneration for them but
can they claim expenses yeah they can
claim expenses yeah to the people who
might not know yeah they can claim
expense I think it's that it's quite a
hard sell it is unremuniated
um
but yeah we'll cover expenses
travel that Etc
and then here's your cool lens So within
five decision of the decision five days
I will climb
it is working oh well done Tom yeah so
five working days you can call in so
um the chair can call in or free members
of ons
um so you can speak to councilor cutter
honkin and most of the call-in or free
members or in the alternative for
members of of council as a whole
um
and then we generally
um put it on the next ons agenda
um
and this is what we've had confusion
before when um when ones have been
called in
um and then what happens if Owen s so
ons have the right to either agree the
decision or make a different
recommendation an alternative
recommendation now if oweness are making
an alternative recommendation to say CNR
then it has to go back to CNR first of
all for them to consider Owen s's
recommendation
um if there's a disagreement between
ons have recommended and what CNR are
recommending then it has to go to full
Council for full Council ultimately to
make that decision
so it can take some time that's good
because you're then you've called it to
where we're nurse you then need to wait
for the next CNR if CNR don't agree it
you then need to wait for the next full
Council if CNR do agree yet then it will
be implemented then
sorry to be pedantic but working days
does that include a Saturday no no
and it's not pedantic because it's a it
can be critical when you've only got
five days
so these are some of the organizations
um although these are the organizations
that came and spoke at
um last
um external over nurse
um
some of them we fund some of them we
don't I would suggest
um at the very least on your forward
plans you would want to be calling the
ones that we do fund and because that's
critically important and that's active
torrage citizen citizens advice
Burton art gallery
um
the there's other ones that I have been
considering before the meeting so we do
quite a lot of work with Pickwell
um in relation to the Ukraine
resettlement
um other organizations such as Encompass
as well and then obviously you have the
choice to
um call over external agencies that you
think are are important
um the only downside to that is we can't
make or compel external agencies to
attend and speak to us or answer our
questions
um Karen will always try our best to get
them here
um and sometimes we've had more luck
than others but
with the ones that we do funds such as
the Burton art gallery that it's a
condition of their contract that they do
um come and
obviously speak and that you know
we are they're contractually obliged to
um detail their performance monitoring
and stuff like that to us
um
this is quite a helpful
and handbook um the local government
Association is really good at doing
um some guides Tom's going to email this
around
um to you after the meeting for those of
you who are interested
take any any questions that's just a
very brief run through
um
what do the first slide Tom please
the um I was interested to hear your
comments about working with the with the
police Stacy how often do we actually
get the police into the office giving
reports or whatever and to whom do they
give them
so we have joint meetings with the
police and of organizations
um the fire service I think roughly
um once a month
um
the other thing that we've been doing
recent was starting from last year was
those joint operations I think you might
have gone on did you go on one street
which was good but we're going to start
that again now and with the police and
the difficulty as cancer bushby is not
even from our perspective it's from the
the police's perspective it's a lack of
resources on their part but we really
want to hit it quite early this year
um to stop the anti-social Behavior I
mean councilor Hodgkin it's been one of
her passions as well when councilor
Hackett has been going to the police and
crime commissioner meetings
um
we've started our own campaign as you'll
see regarding the dog fouling and we've
done a few prosecutions and but we can't
do it alone but we find that even if we
if we start the patrols and we've got
the police with us there first of all
that it's much easier to go it alone
because we've kind of already had that
presence from the police but
um if you want reports directly I can
arrange for the community safety team to
send that through to you because I know
that we've had
um quite a lot of antisocial behavior in
Biddeford recently I wasn't sorry I
wasn't thinking so much about having
reports I mean I I'm grateful for the
work that has clearly taking place
um what I am concerned about is is the
frequency that our senior officers meet
with say the the inspector you're in
Sierra you know I would like to see a
regular calendared Monday morning
meeting
or Friday afternoon meeting whatever
they want so that you know the officers
and the police are all on the same page
yeah you know because there's so much
going on in the town I think it's
important they used to have it years ago
that the inspector would come into the
office and speak to a senior member
that's a cheap example or whatever but
you you have that sort of
that partnership
you know really really closely in
working together and I think that's
something that's been sadly lacking in
the past you know which is why you know
for for such a long period of time
Target has had such a decimal record
when it comes to anything like
enforcement particularly you know the
dog failing issue that you know you
mentioned and it's great that that's
happening now but you know I think we
need to get that
that regular meat Encounters calendared
in throughout the inspector knows that
he's going to come in on Monday and you
know
have that meeting
so um Toby Davies is coming to full
Council on the next full Council
thank you chair
um thank you councilor Busby I agree
entirely with that um councilor Hackett
and I went to a meeting with the priests
and crime commissioner about three weeks
ago now we actually were lucky to get
about 20 minutes direct one-on-one with
the new
Constable at that stage we managed to
convince him to come up to torridge
we've got a date in the diary who's
actually going to come up and see what
the issues are and he'll pass it down
the line we did say that all the
officers we had on the ground were doing
a terrific job but they were they were
struggling for for numbers that was the
issue and the same apply applied to
Great Torrington because last year as
you're probably aware we had this
terrible problem with with fire raising
and it's just saying to them it's not
all in the south coast and that not
Devon is crying out for a police so he
is going to come on and and look
specifically at torridge
[Music]
speeding so in some of our rural
Villages that's an issue but we haven't
got the people to enforce it you just
talk about lack of enforcement so
there's all these variety of issues
linked to the police
that we need sorry councilor Ben
oh thank you um it's actually directed
at Stacy um you mentioned in your
summary the control issue that we have
this ability to have request callings
for control and then you mentioned the
initiative that Cheryl took which
actually was a very appreciated
initiative by most people I know
um I think we're representatives of the
people servants and Servants of God and
um
theoretically you know if people have
concerns we should respond to them and
represent them to whatever Authority is
concerned especially when it's a Public
Authority or a National Authority and
there was absolute consternation that
Cheryl received this idea that it was
disallowed to begin with and I think
it's important to actually clarify what
we mean by control you know it's not
just well surely it's not just stuff
that we have authority over that we make
the decisions over it's about important
issues that affect our community
possibly to their detriment and we're
not suggesting that we have a control
over Glastonbury although I know lots of
people in go to Glastonbury but about
issues where there is clearly a public
interest and public concern and Public
Funding
going into something
surely we don't need to have control
over that we have of concern a
legitimate concern and I'd just like to
have that clarified because obviously it
did cause a problem at the time that
people some people felt that she
shouldn't have even interfered sort of
thing and yet here she was a
representative of the people of
Biddeford and Torrington and holdsworthy
Etc concerned that her constituents were
being had a problem that she couldn't
even get involved in and I think that's
quite an important issue really and
something external because scrutiny
should always be on top of because with
these contraction of local government
there's a lot of areas now where their
arms length and all these other quasi
governmental bodies that act as if they
don't belong to the people anymore sorry
just a bit of a dietary what is your
answer no no I agree
um
you should raise any issues that that um
your constituents have a concern over I
guess from toridge's perspective
um
what we can't do and that's what what
briefly explained earlier I mean you can
always make representations to anybody
um or any outside organization but we
can't compel people to answer if we're
not funding them
um and we can't compel those external
organizations to attend our scrutiny
committee so you're you're well within
your rights to answer
even on your own as a counselor or or
through committee that's absolutely fair
but what we can't do is make those
external organizations attend and answer
our questions and I think sometimes
members feel frustrated by that
sometimes officers feel frustrated by
that but we have no power you have more
power as a committee to make those
recommendations because we can compel
the ones that we fund to attend and or
um usually that's a contractual
obligation for them to attend but I
guess that's that's the diff that's the
point that I was trying to make so sorry
if I did confuse matters I think it was
a notice of motion as well full Council
rather than through the accident
but but it's about yeah things that
affect the people of tourage and that
was why it was put back on the agenda
the following meeting when it was
reconsidered and thought actually it
does affect the people of storage even
though Dartmoor isn't in our district
people here but through the chairs or it
was a it's a broader issue really where
something is deemed by councilors to be
important enough to make representation
I take your point that we can't force
anybody to do anything in certain
circumstances but the power of the
representatives of Victorious
making that petition or complaint to the
powers that be whoever they may be has a
huge effect and it shouldn't be
um dispensed I think we're going to try
and strike a balance between inviting in
people that we do fund and are compelled
to come and inviting people who we'd
like to attend and hopefully they will
but if they don't we can keep inviting
until people do it just just to clarify
though external scrutiny or scrutiny
committees and notice the motion are
slightly different in our so a notice of
motion does have to really if a notice
of motion is presented to full Council
that does have to be something that's
within towards control
um and and unfortunate you know
unfortunately first time round with that
notice of information just to clarify
because it was Dartmoor it was thought
to be outside storage control then with
some more conversation as you know
Cheryl raised it that it did affect
inhabitants so that that's fine so
noticeabation has to external is a
slightly different different mechanism
any other questions or query
um yeah councilor bispy I was just going
to clarify you more that's what you've
already said no but you know the issue
that comes to Brenton I think was
referative was indeed the dartboard
issue when you notice a motion was
refused uh on the first uh in the first
round and I think you know Senior
Management I think I've learned a lesson
with that I've certainly learned a
lesson without looking at the uh the way
that actually went it was a little bit
embarrassing I think to be perfectly
honestly do uh and I don't think it I
don't think it'll happen again so
thank you councilor
this next and
is the forward plan is that right yeah
consideration of the forward plan
so um we don't actually have to fill in
that whole year because we can update it
as we go throughout the meetings if
things arise that we'd like to put on
future meetings but it'd be good to get
the first
few
um
populated with people that we'd like to
invite in
say 19th of July is the next one I would
like
um to invite in Devon County Council
about mental health provision and the
closure of the link centers we've
already agreed to write a letter
inviting them so if we could invite them
to the 19th of July because I think it's
Paramount that they come as soon as
possible people in agreement
is that yep do we vote do we vote for
that just let them no okay
um
and 13th of September it says at the
bottom about having a joint meeting with
North Devon Community safety partnership
which is usually September October so I
don't know if that whether we try and
get that one there
a chair I think um this year round it's
um North Devon's turn to organize the
meeting so I'll contact them and and
start that process okay so that'll be
held a friend's worthy
um I think so but we usually based it
around
um the chair the chair is Toby Davies
usually and it's sort of based around
his Diaries of the day the date does
sometimes change so that's another one
where we'll have that police contact and
we can raise our concerns there Council
Hudson
um I don't want to correct but I went to
the last Community safety partnership I
attended the meeting and that was in
Princeton yeah it was actually so it
should be it should be our turn to so
that was our turn but um we didn't have
a venue because of um so brinsworthy was
used basically but it that was our oh
okay
that I was in a meeting that was being
hosted by right
um
when you're looking at this forward plan
we talked about that we had a list of
who we'd
spoken to with sort of time scales of
how long has it been since we had them
in uh when do we get the opportunity to
add to that list for consideration of
being an item that we'd like to look at
is that the appropriate time now to
mention those yeah I have a couple of
things that I'd like to bring forward I
would like to bring forward
on a positive note
um to here have a presentation from
Harland and wolf about how they're
growing their Workforce how they're
introducing apprenticeships and how they
see their future and Northern Town
councilors had a presentation from them
and they all found it really useful
because it's a positive piece of news
the other things that I'd like to see is
I'd like to see the environment agency
um and flood schemes and working how
we're working together to address those
issues and that's all part of the sort
of big water picture I believe
um somebody mentioned speed watch
there are various services that the
police are involved with
um speedwatch and police advocacy is one
Element crime prevention is another and
I wondered if we could have a sort of
um police day workshop
to actually look at all the different
aspects of policing neighborhood
policing dealing with anti-social
Behavior working in Partnership so that
we could actually have a look at all
those things
and that might actually attract members
of the public to come and listen yeah
I'm just wondering if that might be
appropriate for the whole Council have
we got anything planned and training
time
on that side of things
um the like police training for councils
because before we had like different
tailored workshops simply for home like
a few years ago we did bite size yeah
but trainings for us on cyber crime and
the uh
county lines
and various
and they were really really effective
they were sort of a lunchtime hour with
the local police force delivering those
and and they were really helpful and
cyberprime hasn't gone away as we all
know I think the wider Council would
big benefit from that as well
should we put that on the action yeah
thank you
one of the other seven
one of the other subheadings and that
would be modern day slavery because I
attended a workshop on that that
bringsworthy about a year ago and I
think it's very very important
and perhaps also Road Safety so if
you're talking DCC highways possibly so
if you're doing police speed watch maybe
highways should come in on that yeah did
you have any more councilor Hudson
um
councilor Harding oh sorry yeah only the
same kind of thing is
um and what about
um Plymouth and extra University
um telling us what they are hoping to do
with the middle dock it would that be
something that we could do
yeah I'm wondering if we have something
around employment and education whether
we invited pet truck as well I know we
don't want it to have too many people
but if it's all around the same sort of
issue maybe we invite Holland and move
some Flex to University and petroc it's
obviously working together a lot with
the apprenticeships and that sort of
thing
I was just going to say on that one
councilor Harding
um there will be a briefing for
councilors on that matter on the
Maritime Center so I I don't know if you
want to have it on external but their
briefing will be coming forward as soon
as as we have further details
and we're going to need to update
um new members as to where we've got to
the
so far anyway so it's
um
well yeah
should we schedule something in for
November for employment opportunities
and education
councilor Benson um well it's a subject
that's close to my heart and I'd like to
have some kind of handle in this
committee on some some information that
comes to it and that's about the state
of
um the social
um care and um uh basically the health
of the of the people of torridge we
recently came up in in the news that
toridge has one of the highest child
poverty
in the country
um I think second on to this we know we
wanted the lowest wages and yet we don't
really seem to have a handle on where
these pockets of poverty are if indeed
they are just pockets and not much more
widespread
um because at the same time you have
quite a diverse community in times some
people seem to be very well off I was at
top and I'm into that Torrington team
with Malcolm Michael malpurgo and you
know there is a cognition of Torres
there and they all seem to be very okay
it was a great evening but um at the
same time we do have a lot of poverty in
particularly Biddeford and other places
and I really do think that we don't
really know enough about that and I
think we should approach possibly a
meeting with social services
to find out what is actually going on in
our community
for the people who have to go to the
food banks I mean we're all collecting
for food banks
but what contact do we have with the
people who are using the food banks and
we're all you know looking at the
problems in our society but the actual
people who are experiencing them you
don't often come into contact with
except for the police possibly
um just so I do think it's important
important issue and perhaps we could
involve
um
tbs in this ttbs in this as well in
terms of their volunteers that are
clearly involved in food banks and that
I think it's an important social issue
that doesn't seem to be on the agenda at
the moment I'll just go just to pick up
on that I was speaking to one of the
organizers at the East Water food pantry
last week and they said roughly they're
dealing with 45 to 50 families per week
and the majority of them are not
unemployed they're working people who
just can't make ends meet
the very important issue I think and I
do think we should have some information
coming from the people who are the cliff
Edge on this I know I'm organizing the
food banks really a few years back we
had I think it was during covert we had
a virtual meeting didn't we where we had
Encompass ttvs and citizens advice all
at the same meeting so um they could
just let me use
I've just got to do things just and
maybe it would be helpful because if
cancer Hodgkin's on the committee for
Devon County if counselor does a report
back when she's had those meetings and
the only other thing that I was going to
mention councilor Brunton is we're um
working quite closely with um tttps and
navigate and campus Because currently
torridge have the household support fund
which is helping um people so what we've
been we've teamed up with them because
um we can obviously help um with some
funding in the short term but to try and
help in the long term with money advice
and ensuring that they're claiming all
the benefits that they're entitled to
housing advice and debt advice so but
I'm very sure that those organizations
would be very happy to come and speak to
you about the work that they're doing at
some point as well
we know they're doing it but we need to
know what they're doing and also the
extent of the problem in our community
because I don't know I know it's there
and I know it's bad but I don't know how
bad it is and and when you see these
reports on the news about child poverty
in our own Community you know really we
should be on top of that
with so we wrote the requests in Devon
County come in specifically about mental
health provision which would Link in
with social care and poverty whether we
could include the two
on that do you think as an addition not
not obviously mental health is a
completely separate issue but it's
coterminous with it so the cabinet
member would be not for both they
wouldn't be able to make any serious
information important
thank you um
I'll not list that we just mentioned was
the housing providers on that list
because I would I think you know as well
as you know the the food bank yes
clearly that that's very important but
equally if not even more important is
the number of people that we've got that
you know are really really struggling
they're in you know unsuitable
accommodation and they you know really
find it difficult to get
um to actually get a property you know
I've got several residents that contact
me you know they've got three or four
children they're in a two-bedroomed
um you know temporary accommodation
somewhere and I'd just like to know
where we are in terms of
you know helping those individuals out
you know whether there's any building
programs going on or whatever and
Authority aren't actually building
anything but uh I think it's important
if this committee actually got a got
first-hand information on that topic
yeah Westwood housing or whoever the
housing providers are and they're that's
one of the problems I think you know
they're fragmented there's quite a few
providers that we work with rather than
just the one
it's not one organization
um Alone
um and in fact I was having a
conversation with the housing manager
um yesterday about it
um trying to encourage the housing
providers to provide bigger properties
but they're saying that their major
cohort at the moment is still two and
three bedrooms so
um they'll go whether the demand is I
mean From torah's perspective
we've dipped a little bit in terms of
how numbers and contemporary
accommodation it's still not great I
think we've gone down from within we
were at 75 we've now gone down to 61
families
um
obviously there's a there's a report
coming to full Council
in relation to what torridge intend to
do but it can't be a tourist program
alone and a lot of this needs to be done
through planning and working with an
enabling officer and
um you know pushing
um some developments forward and it's
quite a big issue really because even
when planning's granted
um the problem that we find as some of
these developers don't don't build out
and we can't make them build our
with this leveling up fund up torridges
supposed to have a um a chance of
wouldn't it be a good idea to think
about and
um you know setting up a like a cot and
building some houses I mean you know we
can change legislation with this and you
know I've had a word we can and you know
and I just think you know it should the
idea should be out there for everybody
to think about
is that a recommendation we could put
forward I'll second that we know of um
uh time councils and Parish Council
who've done that in other parts even of
Devon who've actually built
um with a lot of support and funding of
course have built Community houses that
were for their residents
um it the community has the capital of
Devon has been a spearhead of that in
the past so I don't see why we can't at
least explore that subject and in holes
over the other councilor James is very
passionate about clts as well so how do
we meet well it would touch every
Community I mean it wouldn't be just uh
Town Centric it would be it would be
every community and it's just something
that you know I would hope that we're
actively looking at hopefully behind the
scenes as we are but you know
I think the role of external and
internal gets muddied sometimes and I
think the Partnerships and the financial
Arrangements that we have with our
partners as developers and this may well
be something that will be brought
forward through the internal scrutiny
I'm not suggesting we don't do it but
it's about
making best use of our time and where it
sits more comfortably so that's my only
comment on that and I would repeat that
at internal scrutiny which I also sit on
um the other thing that I thought for
external sorry I know I've done a
shopping list but I have been thinking
about this is DWP
because I think the role that they have
in we're talking about our communities
who are not in work the needs not in
educational
employment
I think those things and how they are
working and engaging with our
communities to get people back into work
and retrained might be really quite
interesting
so
I would like to put that on the list
please
thank you
Stacy are you gonna come back on the
clts yeah I was just going to say so you
can't make recommendations off your own
back like that so your role is to
scrutinize others but um you may be
um it may be good to have a word of
counselor James because he he does do a
lot of work with clts and all I can say
is that report on housing has come into
full Council shortly so that might be
your in rather than so you don't make
recommendations off your own back but
you can call
um decisions in and scrutinize other
things
it is
how because some I know I've tried to
call something into external before and
it's been said well it's for internal
everything not external so how do you
establish witches when it's a call in
because quite often it's internal isn't
it yeah and sometimes
um it's not 100 clear because there are
um
well active torrage is one that I can
think for example that both internal and
external will potentially have a role in
internal because we're funding and
external because it's a
um an external service so
um if in doubt just ask and we'll we'll
we'll tell you the the best best route
um so it's not always Clear Car there
are gray areas so it can be confusing
yeah because when I
I wanted to call something into external
before and it's and said well it's a
budget issue but then we're calling in
external partners because we fund them
but then we're told we can't call it in
because we fund them so it's internal
I guess it again depends on what the
issue is
again we if because it's so much to do
with the funding
but most of the decisions that we make
of the character is over the funding so
then the call in would be internal yeah
can I just agree with you here because a
long time ago in another Universe I was
on this Council
um and then we only had one scrutiny
committee
and it dealt with both sides of these
issues and it didn't seem to do any harm
actually we dealt with the sewage
problems the extension of the key uh the
Easter water Link Road the Torrington
smell I could bore you with a lot of
stuff I feel this council did very well
in
representing the people of this
community and getting there which is
implemented and we only had one scrutiny
committee and I don't really understand
why we've got two now I will try to
adjust to that but I don't understand
why we've got two separate ones because
we don't have to have two we could have
one that dealt with both sides of this
and then your problem wouldn't arise and
actually I
person here of course but I actually
felt we were better off when we just had
the one that and it could perfectly cope
with the budget issue and the moral
issue or the ethnical issue or whatever
the issue was
um so why we've got two now I don't know
we'd have to meet them more regularly I
suppose because we're obviously having
these presentations from extern well we
didn't have as much computer stuff it's
true
and we do take in a lot of information
as an external committee
saying it solved that problem of the
Dilemma of oh who's because that is
another obstacle in the way of solving a
problem or whose problem is it well we
knew it was ours
well just uh yeah I mean you're
absolutely right we only need one
committee and when we when we did the
Constitution review one of the
recommendations was that there was just
one Community
um scrutiny committee and but members
didn't want that so they still wanted
the two two committees so that's where
we are
where are we up to then on the um
for a clan so we've got seven County
July Community safety partnership
September November any proposals from
our long list
I I do think it'd be useful to group
some of them together so we said about
employment and maybe if ttvs encompass
and navigate
and DWP
here we can invite them all and
the only problem is depending upon how
many questions you want you might have
quite a long meeting if you have all of
those organizations at once depending
upon how many questions and I think
before the meeting we need to be
prepared to prepare them with questions
that we'd like them to answer that would
help reduce the length of their
presentations
so it's more concise about what
information we want from them
so Encompass just for example they help
us with our hardship fund and they help
with housing and assisted living and
they also do a lot of Outreach work
ttps do a lot of similar work as well
navigate and they do a lot they're doing
a lot of debt advice and the money
assistance but I'm also what councilor
Brenton was talking about social
policies and that they are trying to
collate information about
where the gaps are and push that back up
do we fund navigate we don't but we that
we they work
the compass work
um so they help us with our housing and
they help with the assisted and living
so
and and with our rough sleepers so we do
part from them yeah
should we invite them to the
December meeting
and how about North Devon plus because
they deal with our grants don't they
yeah that's certainly one that you where
would they
would we invite them on their own or
would they work alongside
another group
no they're just a single organization
yeah
I mean you don't have to necessarily
plan it all today because there might be
other ones that come in and we can keep
that list below that we've mentioned
today I was just going to say the same
basically there's something that may be
happening in my ward that we may need
that body to come to to us I think so we
don't know yet and we'd like to you know
you don't know what's going to be around
because of them free so that we've got
that flexibility to invite people in
um
what have we got so far then
have we got anything in for November
and also we you mentioned the
environment agency because I was
planning if we could have the rivers
trust environment agency Southwest water
Surfers against sewage but then I saw
the notice of motion on full Council
which talks about a working group being
set up so maybe we hold off and find out
whether that working group has agreed at
full Council
there are other issues there where
you've got
um the coastal issues with the Marine
management
what's it called MMO Marine management
order
organization and that's actually all
being reviewed
as we speak
and there's a big new piece of software
coming out about floods and tidal
management
that we could be able to access so that
is going to be launched in January I've
seen the provisional
demonstration of it
so that everybody can access it the
things there that could be really quite
useful the impact on those agendas items
but I think what we need to do is think
it out carefully otherwise we're going
to be giving people very limited time to
speak to us or we're going to have a
meeting that goes on forever yeah
that has happened before and then we
ended up cutting it down from one
organization
yeah
unless you sort of set up panel panels
where you've got several people from
different organizations provided with
the questions and they all give their
organization's response to a more
generic questions it depends what you
want to do if you want to get down to
the nitty-gritty
you're not going to get that from a sort
of generalized answer
any proposals for November I'll put down
employment if that's okay
all in the move
Council Smith thank you um if we're
talking unemployment or employment
um that's maybe when we bring DWP and
slavery in is it all everything's ready
to do everything but I was thinking more
the education side of things there and
the apprenticeships which would be
petruck and Highland and wolf
and then the unemployment as opposed to
unemployment yeah do you know I mean
like yes what what's been done in terms
of apprenticeships and degrees and
um
education so if we invite the pet truck
and Harland and wolf and the university
next to universities I think that would
be quite good together
no but we can invite them and say that
we'd really like them to come
should we leave it at that yeah
okay
yeah
but as that's an urgent issue I think we
should try and get that for that one
yeah is everyone happy with that yeah
okay
um
I think that's everything exclusion for
public it's no public here councilor
Branson it's just a question to a point
of information
um I haven't got any of the minutes on
this computer
I had to use my husband's and I said oh
he's not he isn't here um yeah he was
mentioned of a group called alabari in I
think it was it's a forward plan or
something I can't yeah I have no idea
what that is councilor Manley had put it
on there a few years ago and we never
had them in is that still I'm not asking
to have them in I just want I'm not here
was it on the High Street and yeah I'm
totally ignorant of this organization in
terms of I've heard of them before but I
believe yeah I believe everyone based on
the High Street and
um
they had
um they were doing work I feel like it
was around homelessness or housing
provision and working with Alabama
um yeah actually
um
they've just pulled out of North Devon
because Devon the county did the
consultation on the homelessness but
they pulled out before the results of
that consultation
um so that all links in with the the
mental health the assisted supported
living so they're not no longer on our
Horizon really no unfortunately right
okay that's another thing that we can
put to Devon County yeah
okay
um did I declare the meeting close yeah
thank you